vingt ans déjà le 21 septembre 2001 un
stock de 300 à 400 tonnes de nitrate
d'ammonium explose dans un hangar de
l'usiné azf à toulouse la catastrophe a
fait 31 morts et des milliers de blessés
un spectacle de désolation une région
endeuillée des dizaines de bâtiments
détruits pour un bilan matériel de 2
milliards d'euros et bien sûr les
victimes cherchent à établir les
responsabilités de ce drame une des plus
grandes catastrophes industrielles
survenues en france cette usine
appartenant à la société grande paroisse
filiale d'atofina elle même née de la
fusion de total fina et elf aquitaine
puisque lusine accueille les activités
chimie de total le géant pétrolier et
son ex pdg thierry desmarest peuvent-ils
être mise en cause comme le souhaitent
les parties civiles un procès fleuve à
s'engager durant 18 ans les poursuites
judiciaires parmi les plus chers de
france total récuse toute responsabilité
arguant qu'il n'était pas au courant de
ce qui se passait dans ses entreprises
partenaires il ne serait intervenu selon
leur pdg que pour verser les lourdes
indemnités dues aux victimes près de 2
milliards d'euros versés dont 99% des
dossiers traités à l'amiable en 2009
premier procès le tribunal correctionnel
de toulouse rolex tous les prévenus le
parquet fait appel le 24 septembre 2012
la société grande paroisse et condamné à
225 mille euros damende serge biechelin
l'ex-directeur de l'usiné à trois ans de
prison dont un avec sursis et 45000
euros damende total et son ex pdg pour
leur part sont relaxés et condamnés font
appel et l'affairé renvoyée devant la
cour d'appel de paris le 31 octobre 2010
est le jugement tombe l'ex directeur du
complexe chimique est condamné à 15 mois
de prison avec sursis et dix mille euros
d'amendé pour homicides et blessures
involontaires et grande paroisse la
filiale de total à 225 mille euros
damende lusine aurait explosé à la suite
de la mise en contact accidentel de
produits chlorés et du nitrate
d'ammonium ce sont bien les manquements
délibérés dans l'organisation de l'usiné
notamment dans la procédure de
traitement des déchets industriels du
site et la généralisation de la sous
traitance qui sont les causes avérée de
l'explosion la filiale de total et le
directeur de l'ues déboutés de leur
pourvoi en cassation formé un recours
devant la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme cela vient en écho aux affaires
du géant pétrolier total qui compte est
souvent les nombreuses décisions de
justice à son encontre pour corruption
aux sinistres pour la sphère de la
dramatique marée noire due au naufrage
du navire erika le groupe total avait
aussi était jusqu'en cassation pour
réfuter sa condamnation à une amende de
375 me l'euro 2016 le groupe avait tenté
la pelle pour contester la condamnation
à 750 milles euros pour des faits de
corruption dans le contexte du programme
pétrole contre nourriture en irak sans
compter les autres condamnations que le
groupe n'a pas réfuté prochain démêlés
de total énergie avec la justice son
face à face avec six ong qu'il accuse 10
d'action climatique beau programme
judiciaire mais que retenir du drame
d'azf les entreprises à la tête
d'installations classées seveso sont
elles mieux contrôlées pour éviter de
nouvelles catastrophes en croire les
associations de prévention des risques
industriels non entre 2016 et 2018 on a
enregistré 25 % d'accidents
supplémentaires sur les installations
classées et dans le même temps des
inspections de ces sites sont passés de
30 milles à 18000 196 dans le périmètre
des usines seveso les entreprises manque
d'accompagnement pour se protéger en cas
de sinistre et seuls 600 logements sur
16000 ont bénéficié des travaux
obligatoires de mise en protection sans
parler de la gestion de crise qui a mis
en évidence à criant manque de
coordination et de communication
il a fallu dix huit ans pour condamner
la filiale de total combien de décennies
faudra-t-il attendre pour une gestion
optimale du risque industriel en france